avec le soleil arrive laisser bleus avec
les serveurs et les vacances et quand
c'est des vacances on va l app store
oh
comme cela
être à la plage c'est souvent l'occasion
de ramasser des tas de coquillages et
des coquillages
il y en a de toutes sortes des petits
des gros d allonger des ans roulait bref
de toutes les formes et de toutes les
couleurs
comprenons que les classer en fonction
de leur ressemblance et de la se
ressemblent beaucoup
mais il ressemble beaucoup moins
cheminot qui ressemble encore beaucoup
moins à celui là alors on les classe
dans des boîtes
voici la petite boîte des coquillages
dont les valves s'articuler ne sont pas
enroulés et voici la boîte des
coquillages dont les coquilles sont
enroulés comment expliquer une telle
ressemblance à l'intérieur des boîtes
comme incidence non la réponse la plus
vraisemblable et l'ascendance
l'existence d'un ancêtre commun qui se
ressemble s'assemble
et de la même façon que les membres
d'une même famille se ressemblent ces
coquillages doivent appartenir à la même
famille est donc partagé un ancêtre
commun lointain la même chose est
certainement vrai pour les coquillages
aco qui enroulait ces deux groupes
partagent certainement un ancêtre commun
dont la quotité lettres anglais et tous
ensemble ils appartiennent à la famille
des mollusques dont l'ancêtre commun est
encore plus lointain et devait posséder
un corps mou est une coquille en voulez
ou non que ces ensembles deux
coquillages que vous avez trouvé sur la
plage c'est faire l'hypothèse que leur
ressemblance a été dit
c'est trop commun à partir duquel ils
ont évolué classez vos copies yacks et
vous verrez révolution